[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Une famille saine a dévoilé tout son voile
militaire
le corail roche de valentí est connu sous le nom de
l'eau mais
et qui jouit de la patrie libre et
film documentaire
regarde tous les travailleurs
bon
plaines pour le communisme
[Musique]
Oh
et nous allons
et
[Applaudissements]
donc si je portais le même uniforme et
J'ai aussi dit que ce serait comme Elche
c'était il y a plus de 20 ans et je me souviens
que Cuba était comme un paradis
un endroit insouciant
angoisse sans violence
ici l'argent n'avait aucune valeur
le matériel était sans importance et non
existé dans le chômage ni la religion
sur cette île chaude la solidarité
régnait partout nous tous
nous avons ressenti la même chose et pas dans les rues
il n'y a pas eu de publicité ou de précipitation
[Musique]
Je me souviens qu'il était très content
Je nage pour le communisme
[Musique]
et
et le monde
mieux
[Applaudissements]
je te raconte
[Musique]
grâce à ses textures de peinture
la beauté en cette saison
[Musique]
vouloir voir
maintenant après l'avoir tué
continuation
et je parie qu'aujourd'hui nous allons dormir
mais non
[Musique]
et très riche
en farine
Ouais
un gros
toujours envoyer une semaine entière un
jour par semaine pour que nous ayons un
jour
il s'attendait à ce que lentement les petits bus passent
à l'eau qui chante tes yeux
j'étais dans la céramique
il a été
céramique industrielle et j'étais dans les agrumes
des arbres fruitiers qui n'existeraient pas si la céramique était
une primaire sera mon point enregistré que
nous avons fait ces points
social une pile de figurines
tu étais alors
Ils ont été une fois emmenés dans une usine
céramique de ça oui
du même du cycle dans les morceaux
céramiques par des moules comme eux mais
comme dans le processus
[Musique]
quand certains enfants n'ont pas vraiment
au moins les enfants du cube n'ont pas
bien d'autres visions œuvres pionniers de la
pionnier que vous n'avez plus de choix et
ça vient comme si tu allais t'arrêter
préscolaire du 1er au 2ème perdicera la
l'école l'école les carrés étaient
divertissant ils étaient ennuyeux ils ne m'appellent pas
récréation
et un très bon snack à Merida
donner un soda à une génétique de chocolat
et
nous sommes entrés dans le soda l'action
l'école continue pour les ventes en ligne
c'est diférent
la plus petite salle de classe
et maintenant absolue avec une cartouche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mes amis et moi étions des pionniers et
nous avons grandi en participant à un projet
construisons une nouvelle société
une société juste
nous connaissions un mode de vie différent et
harmonieux
nous avions tous un toit et notre
les parents avaient un travail garanti
l'état nous a fourni
matériel scolaire et école
médecins et dentistes sont venus
ils ont vérifié notre bonne santé
nous les pionniers étions les
façonneurs du futur et nous serions les
nouvel homme qui avait imaginé elche
tout nous paraissait possible nous serions
médecins cosmonautes ingénieurs physiciens
peintres sportifs
que je suis de retour à l'école primaire
sans préoccupations
où rentrer à la maison nous allons arriver
comme il a déjà fait 9 petites poupées
ne fait pas mes devoirs
[Musique]
comment ça s'appelle
éducation musicale
Eh bien, il a été mis à la radio et j'ai pris
quoi avoir lalalala
[Musique]
quelle bonne chose j'ai dit plus haut maintenant chante
toi et Alicante
telam
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Oh
Talará était le camp principal de
pionniers qui étaient à La Havane et c'était
partie de notre paradis d'enfance
nous sommes venus en vacances et pendant la
les écoles de l'année scolaire ont déménagé
terminer jusqu'ici pour continuer le
Des classes
se trouve quand ils mentionnent que riche
C'était la plus belle des belles maisons
Un grand passé riche car c'était un parc
amusements la plage avait mon truc pour
Amusez-vous à part puis donnez-moi
j'aimais arroser j'aimais arroser
c'était vendu et parce qu'il y en avait trop
activités parapluie
c'était étonnant
les maisons sont belles
ça me rend triste d'avoir été perdu
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les ruines de nos souvenirs
ils cohabitent avec les nouveaux entrepreneurs
étrangers et avec quelques victimes de
tchernobyl qui arrivent encore pour recevoir
traitement médical
rien n'est ce que c'était
Je sens que mon pays d'enfance a
disparu, seuls les slogans subsistent et
les anciennes structures de ce rêve
que cela avait du sens à l'époque et que je
je croyais
cette maison pour nous était mythique
dans cette maison il y avait pendant 20 ans un
musée d'elche
bingo fixe
original
ce comptoir familial bas
au lieu de cela, la majorité des gens
de la révolution
ensuite
la plupart des jeunes
ils s'identifient à lui
à la possibilité que j'aille au
réduction alors
je ne crois pas
mais ma mère quand le professeur
bien que la visière avec deux couleurs de la
informatisation
mais ce fut avec un triomphe du
révolution cette peau et les aigus
Les dirigeants russes ont proposé l'idée
en alphabétisant le pays a
atteint un pourcentage très élevé de
population analphabète
Ils savent écrire et ma mère était professeur de
un groupe de paysans pour l'abattage
j'avais 17 et 15 ans
à cette machine
la nuit car il sera remis au
travail de terrain à l'école
ils l'ont fait et là il a appris son bluff que
le cours a déjà commencé
J'ai défini les cliqueurs heureux
dans une immense émotion lorsqu'il se rendit
commander chez eux et que la dernière chose
parce que les gens une année entière de plus
vivre avec ces gens là-bas
et ça va continuer à se lisser et c'est après
aller à la salle de travail
les bénévoles est un pilier du travail est
organiser la révolution
[Musique]
plus d'un million d'analphabètes à un
appelé à la révolution une armée de
jeunes hommes car ils ont donné et les montagnes ont emporté
la lumière de l'enseignement à tous
coins du pays écrivent et terrorisent
de l'impérialisme a fait des victimes
l'aiguille avertit les banques de 11 heures
nietzsche et enfin 66 personne n'a eu peur
le 22 décembre 1961 tu nous vois
nous avons réussi à vous déclarer territoire libre
alphabétisation et analphabétisme en un seul acte
sur la place de la révolution à côté
fidel cette tâche était l'une des pages
le plus brillant de notre histoire aujourd'hui
nos gens se préparent à réaliser
une formation générale complète
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
organes
ouah ouah oui non
parfois
C'est comme ça que j'étais quand je suis arrivé à Cuba'
j'avais deux ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon
et comment était cette note
et
et le coup d'état au chili
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mes parents faisaient partie de mon rêve
salvador allende en 1971 fidel est allé à
Santiago du Chili quand mon père
filmé ces images ma mère était
aussi dans la foule avait alors
enceinte de huit mois un mois plus tard
Cuban est né et deux ans plus tard
accueilli
dans ces années-là, beaucoup sont venus
exilés de toute l'amérique latine et
chaque famille que les Cubains sont arrivés d'un
appartement meublé et tout
droits des citoyens
car alors si tu décidais de rester ici
avec moi avec ma soeur
dans ce pays
éducation gratuite de toi moi
travail offert
et c'est pourquoi je ne bouge pas
ceci en partie parce que j'ai un penchant pour lui
si grand si grand
parce que j'avais toujours entendu dire que
les enfants avaient besoin de grandir avec stabilité
et nous étions partis d'Espagne
payable du chili espagne de l'espagne pour
ici d'un hôtel ou d'un hôtel et quand
nous sommes arrivés il y avait environ 15 il y en a un
stabilité pour toi qui étais je pense
c'est très important dans cette stabilité
sur le bouquetin
ces 15 ans
Je pense que ça leur donne une force
je ne sais pas
quand nous sommes arrivés ici la havane tous
ces bâtiments nous sommes finis
construire
peu après mes parents
ils se sont séparés mon père est revenu vivre à
Madrid et nous allions régulièrement à
le voir
andrew ils sont allés à l'école
quartier et nous nous sentons toujours partie de
ce pays nous appartenons à la génération
de Cubains nés et élevés dans les années
d'or de cette révolution
mais avec certains privilèges
[Musique]
mais comme j'ai combiné pour que quand
l'endroit
comme
trois côtés de l'année la note
J'étais ici depuis presque 3 ans
allez
mais égal
[Applaudissements]
nous avons eu un rebond
comme alors
qu'ils mettent toute l'indiscipline qui
nous avons bien comme c'était une quantité de
ici je te fais jouer quand tu portes
trois choses du gualivá nous avons de
disciplinaire et dans les trois
les concessionnaires vous donnent les cordes
c'est ainsi qu'il a été débattu en direct avec
avoir la voix d'un petit sale diego
rapport réalisé par lui dans
En parlant de la formation, je l'ai déjà signalé à
retourner un peu les cheveux un peu longs
ils obtiendront le rapport de remplissage sans quoi
point le pour un autre avait le rapport
j'ai trouvé quelque chose
quelques mois un rebond meurt à ça
vitesse parce qu'il est venu courir pour le
couloirs
bon 4 où d'autre premier jour
que nous sommes arrivés alors j'étais du groupe 1
septième année et nous n'arrêtons pas tout
l'information que le groupe est payé au
entrepôt nous étions toujours en ligne était là
Nous en traversons un il y en avait comme un
commun montré 14ème siècle
et nous ne sommes pas nés personnels et non
J'ai dû être losantos pour voir les toilettes
ils m'ont donné les uniformes
uniformes les bottes
et ne pas sortir de là les cahiers
des crayons
voiture marine qu'acteur
nom
[Musique]
ce n'était pas bon
donc la marine
[Musique]
d
plus réel à une villa María Vázquez et le
malt
le goûter était comme tous les vendredis
donnant en mettant un le matin et un
poussière pour l'arabie
comme les taux de change
80 il y avait beaucoup ici
Jacques
[Musique]
il
en septième année à la radio et
après le calcul
créer un espoir
et
et la radio avec
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
que la population goûtée et morte
on suppose que
qui liait l'étudiant au travail
à l'étudiant qui a une idée de ce que
est de travailler et d'étudier à l'info - et que
c'est bien de ce coté là mais le travailleur
il a voté révélé
avec le matin je travaille comme enseignant ou à
inverse
[Musique]
On vient délivrer les noirs qui déjà
nous utilisons
et les cahiers dans la tête oui oui quoi
Nous avons déjà ramassé la majorité des cahiers
de marchandises ou de cahiers
bons crayons
Gomez
[Musique]
que veux-tu que nous fassions
mais ce n'était pas toi
Yo
parmi les livres de biologie il faut
pour ma carrière c'est ce que nous recherchons
voir la préparation
bon je veux la biologie de la microbiologie
comme des bons voeux de ma part
joue plus
la préparation militaire reste un
matière au lycée
C'est vrai qu'ils nous ont toujours dit que le
pays pourrait être envahi à tout moment
moment et nous devions tous être
prêt à le défendre
mais la vérité est que je n'en ai pas
Je me souviens m'être senti en danger
[Applaudissements]
c'est une invention
dans une maison familiale que nous avons tous
maison et toit
mais tous dans le même toit
le même que parfois très joli car
tu vis avec ta famille tu vis avec ta
parents avec qui vous vivez tous
générations qui vivent ensemble
tu es mauvais parce que parfois
[Musique]
faire l'amour tu dois le faire tu dois le faire
navette
ce qui est moyen était facile pour moi
nous sommes nés un moulin à sucre appelé
maintenant il appelle fort lorsque vous
aidera l'espagnol central
et c'est très bien
qui ont 10 ans 10 ans pour écrire
dans
allez comprendre
tout comme l'enfant cubain étudie et
a l'éducation cette négativité est la
de cette université ne donne plus d'argent
Dans une école cubaine, nous avons étudié où
Ils t'ont appris de belles valeurs
dans la vie comprise comme avant tout
comme une expérience spirituelle plutôt que
matérialiste ou matériel
bien qu'il n'y avait pas de religion mais il y avait la foi
socialiste et communiste qui
[Musique]
nous ne serions pas obligés l'après-midi et
ils vous donneront les bons sous aucun sous
pas d'idéologie
la fameuse autocritique
autocritique m
la bombe l'assemblée des mérites et
les démérites ou la nouvelle attitude de l'assemblée
de
l'autocritique et si je ne te l'avais pas dit
manquait d'autocritique et que tout était dans
loger ou voiture
c'est très laid
contradictoire une partie du partage
tout le monde voulait partager le désintérêt
L'esprit de
détachement
maintenant celui-ci est détruit
il est très dégradé
les années 80 qui étaient des années très voyantes
spécial parce que c'était quand plus
l'économie a fonctionné
il y avait un peu il y aurait de tout de tout un
bit
et il y eut une énorme explosion de
nouveau médicament et les promotions de
des cabines d'essayage se faisaient dans ce
moment où l'éducation faisait là
Carlos Arias parlait du
réalité quand on parle de réalité
des choses de tous les jours
le langage était un peu plus direct
était plus
Non
oui plus proche de tout que de tout
problème actuel quel était
qui se passait à ce moment-là et que je pense
qui est fait par des chroniqueurs un chroniqueur de
ce qui se passe
et avoir
mémoire et
[des rires]
inclus car nous cherchons un peu
détruit
inclus dans la mémoire mais pas
[Musique]
disons une pile d'amis avec un
musée de la guitare 18 on fait un petit
nous avons rencontré des jeunes de
connaissant poètes narrateurs peintres
c'était fou si nous chantions pour moi
là-bas dans les paiements que la promenade
dit toutes les personnes découvertes par le
le temps n'avait pas été de découvrir la prochaine
ils étaient je dis un moment une ambiance très
magnifique avec beaucoup de poésie
[Musique]
des concerts avaient lieu chaque semaine
des endroits comme celui-ci dans d'autres beaucoup plus
grand et nous avons chanté fort ces
chansons d'amour et de protestation
donc ils commençaient
membres de la havane ouverte
Ils vivent à Madrid depuis 10 ans.
et c'est la première fois qu'ils reviennent pour
donner un concert
[Musique]
celui qui voulait beaucoup
une image en pensant
pour chaque jeu
le regarder à la lumière des années
nous croyions aux chansons et à la capacité
transformer les choses avec la chanson
que non seulement nous ne l'avons pas vécu les humains
n'est plus dépendant mais c'était très intense
ce sentiment que cela pourrait être fait
la création de choses en général est très
comme naïf très cool
tout tres beau beaucoup de couleurs
Pas vrai
et nous vivions dans un nuage
J'ai conventionnellement maintenant en Espagne et
Je vais vous dire un peu comment nous vivons comme les
Les Grecs
Je recommande quatre jeux et penser à
choses grandes et nobles
démarrer sur terre et un moteur
C'était la société qui attendait un moyen
dédier l'état
Et comment aimes-tu revenir
allez bon oui
C'etait ça
une chose qu'une autre planète n'avait ni
même rien avec quoi en russie dans le
autres pays
ce qui a été vécu ici est le même chaque réalité
ses gènes sont uniques non mais le
nous étions super uniques
C'était très rare, une très grande chose.
et c'était très sympa tout baquet évidemment
C'est maintenant que j'ai d'autres souvenirs
maintenant ils auront été victimes de représailles et non
Cela aura été
il n'y en a pas beaucoup, pas comment penser
différent
mais
j'ai un très grand bonheur non
Je pense que la plupart d'entre nous et c'est ce que
que nous portons à l'intérieur et c'est pourquoi nous continuons
Être heureux
et nous avons eu une enfance super heureuse
avec toutes les choses qui ont toujours
été la la
et les mauvaises choses qui ont toujours eu
pas tout ça
mais que ces choses se sont aggravées
crise à cette époque c'était très facile
les ignorer ou du moins pas
ce n'est pas la peine de s'angoisser pour le trouver
ce jour-là il y avait de la nourriture
il n'y avait pas de bus
à côté des pannes d'électricité, je ne savais pas que le
l'argent était le moindre
aux barrières dit une chanson qui
personne ne parle jamais d'argent tasio
Il parle d'argent, il ne m'intéresse pas
argent ou être
ce qui s'est passé période spéciale bien
Je compterai les terribles
tout était un grand miroir une grosse bulle
qu'ils avaient créé mais qui n'était pas réel
nous ne pouvions pas rester seuls
eux-mêmes
nous n'avions rien
quoi offrir au monde
vous pouvez garder cet état
nous changeons la politique pour le pétrole
à la politique de cesser de cotiser
a extrait de l'huile
et développé non
les trois dernières années de la guerre froide
Ce furent les années les plus heureuses de ma vie
J'ai étudié dans cette pré-université
[Applaudissements]
Je me souviens que c'était cette époque pleine de
liberté et euphorie
mais je me souviens aussi que c'était quand
J'ai commencé à planter dans le système avec son
les bureaucraties et leurs emplois de contrôle
volontaires obligatoires le manque de
tolérance
efe
Voyons d'où cela vient
quand j'ai commencé avec tout le monde
le monde se souvient exactement de cette heure
rien après beaucoup de lecture et beaucoup
[Musique]
bien sûr parce que nous étions
très facile
J'ai attendu le bus pendant trois heures et
Cela ne s'est pas produit mais nous avons attendu le 201 là-bas
et j'ai regardé il y a énormément mieux mais
bon
effectuer
[Musique]
est une nation de tout plat
et ces trois-là ont beaucoup accompli
mais non
passé
[Musique]
non non Non
Il n'est plus logique que lorsqu'il combine
avec eurosport
comme
[Musique]
d
et tu as quatre bois
[Musique]
Je m'appelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quel changement
tout
et les gens
[Musique]
la société
le chemin de
[Musique]
la forme du moteur à laquelle l'argent va
nous vivons tous
la période de tout a commencé
différent
peut partir le bonheur entrera
dans le malheur
Les visages étaient difficiles et maintenant c'est tout
vraiment les gens se sont dépassés depuis
cette étape qui a endossé très difficile
très difficile pour tout le monde
derrière tu dois déjà essayer de survivre
avec quelques-uns comme toujours
Nous allons adapté quand il entrera par le
Je marche et tout a cessé d'entrer
le pays qui commissionne
était complètement dépendant
[Musique]
cela jamais
selon la base ils ont donné plus
[Musique]
jamais arrivé est ce communisme est
moins catalans de cette façon que nous sommes
vivre maintenant que tu ne l'as pas
vous n'êtes pas venu un système défini
ni socialisme ni capitalisme et pas ici
nous finirons par le socialisme
nous irons un peu plus loin nous aurons un
capitalisme nouveau module 20
le capitalisme a formé l'ouest
Je n'oublierai jamais quand la voiture
présidentiel avec gorbatchev je suis passé
devant
elle est excitée et pleine d'espoir
parce qu'il croyait à la perestroïka dans cette idée
d'un monde plus ouvert et plus
tolérant et vraiment pensé que c'était
possible de faire une révolution au sein
cette révolution
il y avait des visites officielles et des discours mais
Je n'ai pas compris ce qui s'est passé et
Je n'aurais jamais imaginé que c'était
le début de la fin
quelques mois plus tard le mur de
Berlin
J'ai vu ces images comme tant d'autres
plusieurs années plus tard
ce jour-là le journal nous annonçait ainsi
nouvelles
l'année 89 fut une année étrange commencée au
la fin de la guerre froide et aussi le début
la fin sans fin de pinochet
Ici, nous avons vu le procès du général Ochoa
condamné à mort pour trafic de drogue
et cette même année nous avons reçu avec les honneurs
les corps arrivés d'angola
et pour la première fois le
noms des milliers de Cubains qui
mort dans tant d'autres pays en
nom de la révolution
ton piment était mon meilleur ami à l'époque
de la pré-université
C'est la première fois que je reviens et ça déjà
il n'est pas là
non non
une fois
[Musique]
le 25 novembre 2000
qui est passé par là
à la tombola
que un
un mécanisme de migration institué par
la
accords d'immigration entre cube
États-Unis d'avoir une manière organisée de
émigrer et éviter le problème de
les chevrons des sorties illégales ou
au moins adoucir
c'est comme ça qu'on l'appelle
[Musique]
Oh
ils ne disent pas
les systèmes fiscaux ici à Cuba
ils ont amené leurs irréguliers
ses ennuis mais comment c'était
activé à un moment où tout
c'est assez serré
et tout était si changeant parce que la date
notez qu'ils sonnent en même temps dans
que le pain était limité à un par personne
à peu près au même moment où ils ont commencé
inventer les chameaux
que tant de choses ont commencé à partir qu'il
la douleur fiscale était
traumatisant mais pas si traumatisant parce que
est venu à l'intérieur beaucoup de
de situations et de conditions
Je compte pour la boisson
et tu allais à bicyclette comme j'allais
pour travaux dans l'année
[Musique]
et un camion vous a dépassé deux camions par
à côté
les avenues étaient complètement vides
[Musique]
était un vai presque complètement pour
de nombreux changements ne voulaient pas aller quelque part
côté, ils devaient aller à vélo ou
marchant bien nous avions la télévision
vous pourriez parfaitement réussir les trois
heures d'attente pour un trampoline
beaucoup de choses ont disparu
de l'habitude de tant de gratuité est
que même à ce moment nous commençons à
payer plus ou moins grand-père et grand-mère
les eaux usées qui n'ont pas été facturées
légère augmentation des prix
et augmentation des prix
alors ça sent le travail de mesure
perplexité mais non nous ne le sommes pas
merci
nous avons une très grande capacité d'extraction
grand
alors que nous nous adaptons pour recevoir le
Quoi
nous venons vous voir
comme nous avions l'habitude de le faire
familles divisées
comme on s'y habitue
la nuit pour mettre les garçons
le matin
comment on s'habitue à se baigner
et non
prendre le petit déjeuner sans lait
la corne sans grâce
aspect qui n'est pas pané
[Musique]
en 1991 alors que les pays d'Europe
de l'est converti au capitalisme
ici, ils ont décidé de résister et le
slogan socialisme ou mort
J'étais à Madrid et bien la distance
à la disparition de l'union soviétique
immédiatement ici ils ont décrété la période
surtout les rues étaient remplies de
vélos avec lesquels les maisons étaient éclairées
bougies les gens ont perdu du poids et sont partis
mettre fin à l'illusion
le dollar a été légalisé et le
inégalité
depuis lors, l'île a connu plusieurs
métamorphose
grâce au tourisme et aux envois de fonds
parents l'économie s'est redressée
mais maintenant il y a deux mondes un dans
devises et une autre en monnaie nationale
[Musique]
l'Etat garantit toujours une base minimale
de nourriture mais plus de salaire
ne suffisent à rien et celui qui n'en a pas
l'entrée de devises doit inventer
[Musique]
J'ai dit que cette semaine le poisson arrivait
oeuf et poulet
déjà cette semaine
mais
un repas avec un œuf d'où il n'y aurait pas de vol
dire
un repas dure deux ou trois jours de plus
en quelques semaines plus tard tout est
qu'ils vous donnent de la viande en plus de fibres
[des rires]
pas ici des années
[Musique]
et ainsi
mais ce sont ces coupons mais sinon
ils ont et avant plus que tout ce qu'il y a
chaussures en tissu plumes
une demi-semaine de tout et même des fils
sur les routes
Alors qu'est-ce que tout le monde vole?
le travail qui marche
ensuite
[Musique]
J'ai aussi vu un monde du monde entier
vivant
et que nous avons travaillé
[Musique]
les adolescents d'aujourd'hui n'ont jamais cru
dans cette nouvelle société que nous
construisons ils ne savent pas qui gorbatchev
et ils n'ont pas entendu parler du mur de berlin
ils me semblent étrangers et je suis surpris de les voir
faire les mêmes choses que moi
c'est l'école que le domaine est et était
partie du système éducatif chaque
étudiants du pays viennent travailler dans
l'agriculture ici nous apprenons quelle est la
emploi
[Musique]
bien que nous l'aimions tellement pourquoi
et nous étions aussi sans la pression de
parents
sur les anniversaires de pays est un
cadeau de la région une banque je ne sais quoi
[Musique]
Être ici, c'est comme entrer dans un
machine à remonter le temps tout est exactement
égal
[Musique]
ensuite
ce n'était pas aussi mauvais que d'autres fois
Je payais la bombe aux fruits avec le soleil
pour nous et le manque d'eau que nous n'avons pas
rien de plus que l'eau stagnante
c'était si mauvais
et s'ils ne manquent jamais et qu'en plus de
travailler nous sommes toujours ensemble les gens
de la classe nous nous sommes amusés
comme ces choses si nous ne le faisons pas
on peut faire à la havane pour ça
béni
Oh
la vérité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Aujourd'hui c'est le 28 janvier et comme toujours
des marches pour célébrer
naissance de notre héros national José
marti
Quand j'étais enfant, peu étaient fabriqués.
marches par an et je me souviens que je suis allé avec
enthousiasme
maintenant des actes sans fin sont faits
politiciens dans la vraie raison
avant il y avait beaucoup de gens qui vraiment
croyait au projet et aussi
bien-être matériel personnes soutenues
heureux que nous ne nous sentions pas comme un satellite
Soviétique et peut-être était-il plus facile de ne pas
questionner quoi que ce soit et tout simplement pas
penser
[Applaudissements]
Ce n'est que maintenant que je réalise que si ça n'a pas été le cas
dit que je suis avec le système était parce que
Je suis parti et je suis resté avec un souvenir
idyllique de quelque chose qui n'a peut-être jamais été
sous le regard scrutateur de l'âme
mater des milliers de Cubains brandissant
Escalier payé au flambeau
étudiante portant un énorme
drapeau qui a étudié le front civil
[Musique]
Ouais
avec présence dans une partie de l'indra et
souverain
[Musique]
brun
décès de l'hôte
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
il y a de la peur
ne pas éclabousser quelque chose
Désolé
[Musique]
Aux États-Unis
de Miami
il est allé pour le battage médiatique, je le prends dans le battage médiatique
depuis l'an 97
elle avec mon jeune frère que
pourrait entrer dans son étude afin que ce
avait moins de 21 ans célibataire puis
à cette époque j'avais 15 ans et si
je viens
mon frère mon oncle âgé de plus de 21 ans et
maintenant nous pourrions
et mon frère était il y a un an et demi à
L'Espagne et enfin tu peux bouger
Je ne connais pas la situation ici
que d'une part on aime le
pays mais sinon pas
beaucoup de choses qui viennent nous avons le
des portes
il n'est pas du tout chez lui
J'ai moi-même maintenant mon fils mais
la façon dont je vis et vais
mieux faire les choses, c'est pour
l'aide qu'il me donne de l'extérieur
parce que si je devais le faire avec lui
l'argent que je gagne
ils ne pouvaient même pas penser que ni
garde moi
[Musique]
miraculeusement ça ne ressemble pas à une bonne ville
l'alagi a été averti d'un autre front froid
Qu'est que c'est
et nous voulons nous donner un été
nous reçoit je l'ai envoyé sans aucune affection
[Musique]
et malgré les cyclones de l'embargo et
du confinement la révolution semble
continue de résister mais s'en va
son peuple sans rêves
générations collées ensemble
dans les maisons et le quotidien des gens
C'est devenu de plus en plus compliqué
étouffant
tout fonctionne différemment ici que dans le
reste du monde
et 94 lors de la grande crise survenue
ici quand j'ai commencé l'auteur ils l'étaient déjà mais
spécial comme le sont 90 21 24 quand
c'était bon bon fort
j'ai été un peu déçu non
dans la révolution de ce qui s'était passé
pas elle que tout le monde et l'environnement qui
tout était
et puis un jour il a eu la chance d'être
dans la seconde ils virent les états
rejoint
et nous nous sommes inquiétés pour la maison
inquiet comment vas-tu
être vraiment
J'étais très mal supportable ce qui s'est passé avec quoi
truc
jusqu'à 42 ans
a fait de grandes œuvres oubliées
et nous avons déjà miami
Je suis un peu inquiet mille fois
les hommes s'amusent beaucoup la chose
ma mère dans les rangées de feu par
le rencontrer non pas parce qu'il était
le mal vit un peu
Oh
et 88 ans
je suppose qu'on en verra d'autres
Je n'ai pas été chez ma mère depuis 8 ans mais
ce que je voulais te chanter
ils se sont appelés au téléphone
Je commence une affaire de santé
ils ont beaucoup résolu
pour le résultat
ils avaient une autre idée de
de ce qu'il fait
ta vie ou la révolution et quand tu attends
spécial que la posture humaine
ils pensaient que tout ce qu'ils avaient fait
pour ça
quelle petite amie a été envoyée pour rien
et enfin
ça n'avait pas de sens ils l'auraient fait
et donc
ils ont fait ce qui fait beaucoup de famille
ils ont voulu
ils ont quitté le pays quand ils se sont améliorés
économiquement
[Applaudissements]
contrôle et tu resterais
enfin au revoir le jeu de presse de
bouche
quand
[Musique]
mais n'est pas
le magicien gargamel
donc ici ici pas moi
je ne manque de rien
que les tons ne sont pas des choses matérielles
si nous buvons de l'eau qui abrite
[Musique]
c'est pourquoi c'est si quotidien et la nature
Je ne sais pas ce qui s'est passé hier j'étais ici
[Musique]
le problème n'est pas de tout dire
ce qui se passe et en termes de négativité
il y a aussi tout ce qui se passe ici
termes positifs ou est-ce une réalité
qui vous forme avec confiance en vous
qu'avec la capacité avant tout
et vous le remarquez adultes vous sentez que vous
vous concourez que la compétition se fait à un niveau
de concurrence entre les données de
formation antérieure et réalité
précédent qui était ici
c'est vraiment de la chance sur tout
pour notre prochaine génération
IL
nous étions les faussaires de
avenir qui vous donne 30
responsabilités de confiance
aussi
et je le crois
bien que j'aie
et tous
Que si tu étudies ne vaut rien
parce qu'à la fin ce qu'ils veulent c'est être
porteurs un travail modèle dans un
le magasin ou quelque chose comme ça, puis à
tu étudies tu n'étudies plus tu n'étudies plus
vous avez des références et vous n'avez pas de références
ni lecture ni musique ni bon cinéma
Eh bien rien ne reste debout dans le coin
du club attendant l'étranger de son
la vie et maintenant le plan a changé et le plan est ce que
Qu'allez-vous faire quand vous sortirez d'ici ?
drôle comme les plans apparaissent bien
Donc
à ces âges
[Musique]
plutôt un problème de pourquoi je devrais
d'être ingénieur, un bureau est jeté
carton sans aucune machine
écrire et gagner 310 pesos parce que parce que
le symposium tu m'as appris que je pouvais
plus loin
et rien d'autre et je peux vivre de mon travail
le plus intéressant je n'ai pas à
penser ou chercher quelque chose d'étrange ou
illégal de survivre et que
la tranquillité d'esprit que de survivre honnêtement
rien n'a été payé
été tous vos amis
ils sont passés du coucou
bon
belle est en espagne
Argentine
à notre en Argentine
derrière paris
le dit que c'est en allemagne le numéro est
en suède humaniste à puerto rico
Carlitos est au Canada et ils l'approchent
al manuel est au canada
[Musique]
voici les hommes dans lesquels Ruben est
Espagne
ta soeur est en espagne
l'expédition espagnole à tampa
à chaque arrêt rogelio est au brésil et
il est en espagne alejandro est en espagne
ppt est en Chine
Alexandre est en Italie
leurs piments sont à miami et là rafa et
raymundo visite aussi est à majorque
dayami est au mexique par mer je pense
est à puerto rico petit elche sont à
Rome
sebastian le stand suisse caroline se tient
au Chili
marlon est à barcelone eduardito dans
new york eric est en australie et en
paris est patricia jennings sergio
lizbeth liván manolito et une pile de
plus de gens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à suivre
radio aragon
en trois minutes
[Musique]
la mangue jaune et la mangue pour
obtenir d'acheter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Informations médicales dominicaines
et justement
et
[Musique]